if there is one thing that is
categorically true about gamers
it's that they can be very
particular whether it's in the rgb
settings on our tech or the character
that we perpetually insta-lock us
capital g gamers sure do love our
freedom of choice that being said not
all choices are advantageous beyond any
doubt there are certain things we can
choose that are going to be objectively
better than others
and this is especially true in the
servers of our two most prolifically
covered tax shooters you see cs go and
valorant are economy shooters which
means that in some respects they are
quite literally mathematical in fact in
order to play these games you don't just
have to be mechanically savvy but
financially as well but there is one
mandate that players across both games
don't always agree on since
admittedly there isn't always a clear
answer
namely
when should you upgrade your armor
although the benefits of buying
additional armor might seem rather
obvious the question of when you should
capitalize on them has actually been a
mildly contentious topic in cs go for
quite some time due to the stats of
certain weapons and the financial stress
that head armor inflicts on the already
fragile ct economy there is an argument
that paying extra to protect your noggin
might not always be the right call now
things have come full circle because
that same conversation is happening
around heavy armor invalorant and we are
even seeing teams opt out of the added
protection at the pro level but is it
the right call can not upgrading your
armor in these games be a big brain
strat or cause more harm than good
well come along and
let's find out
okay so before we dive into all of this
armor conversation i want to very very
quickly ask that you please like the
video subscribe to the channel and if
you are so inclined turn on
notifications also be sure to check out
our new live streaming initiatives liz
and i are going to be streaming once a
week on twitch and i will be streaming
hot retakes live just like you all asked
for on youtube
every week as well so please
if you're down tune in see you there
whether it's siege apex or even dota
armor generally has the same theory it
allows a player to absorb more damage
before they die however the way in which
armor is implemented is completely
different from title to title and
sometimes the explanation of how armor
works can be confusing to say the least
luckily for us for the purposes of this
episode we are only going to be focusing
on cs go and valrant and since this
whole debacle started in counter-strike
we too will start there in cs go there
are two levels of armor kevlar vest and
kevlar vest plus helmet when starting in
any game that isn't casual the player
spawns without any armor to get the
standard kevlar fest the player has to
drop 650
for kevlar and a helmet they gotta drop
a grand
one helmet please
now the intricacies of cs go's armor
infrastructure are actually a needlessly
complicated subject and as a result
there are a ton of videos and articles
breaking it down to the most minute
detail for the sake of our videos
economic focus we will do the best to
try to simplify the mechanical side of
things
basically kevlar protects your torso
groin and arms
and head armor protects
well your head
your face if you take damage with armor
it will absorb a portion of that damage
based on the armor penetration of that
weapon cs go mastermind three clicks
philip made a really solid explanation a
few years ago for simplicity's sake
let's imagine a gun had 50 armor
penetration like the nova or the ct
starting pistols ish
whatever damage it deals to you will be
split 50 50 between your health and your
armor to say a bullet does 60 damage it
would deduct 30 of that from your health
and 30 from your armor leaving you at 70
health and 85 armor because remember
it's made up of 200 hit points so 30
damage to the armor is only 15 of its
total without head armor there are a lot
of guns in the game that will one tap
you due to their headshot damage but for
guns that don't have enough armor
penetration to one shot a helmeted
player such as the m4s the galil famas
usp glock etc they will be dinked
instead
but as a result of some weapons armor
penetration being higher than what the
helmet can protect against they will
still be a one-shot headshot regardless
of whether your head is protected
weapons like the deagle krieg op ogg
keck 9 and 5 7 from close range and most
iconically the ak-47 at least they'll
succeed but they need to win this oh my
lord faith what are you doing he's got
one bullet in it he's three legs got one
bullet oh
scream my hands are shaking but i'm
still shooting i'm still getting the
headset
and herein lies the roots of the
so-called anti-helmet visas since there
are so many commonly purchased weapons
that one shot headshot regardless of
whether you have head armor
why not just not buy head armor and
forego the 350
entirely but since cs go is asymmetrical
this really only applies to the ct side
now this may sound painfully obvious but
for a lot of new players out there
coming from non-tack economy shooters
it may not go without saying cs go is a
game where you want to use the best guns
whenever possible which means that on a
full buy tees are going to be using
either the op or the ak
like a lot of the time two of the
weapons that one shot headshot no matter
the armor one who takes alexey b before
being instantly traded by aloo what a
shot by twandu i assume someone's around
right
the cts aren't afforded that luxury for
balancing purposes both the m4a4 and a1s
take two shots to the head to kill if
the player has a helmet this means that
tees are basically always going to want
to get head armor to protect against ct
weapons since very few of them one shot
through armor but with ct side the
reasons as to one may buy or not by head
armor can get pretty granular so let's
lay them out and work through them not
buying head armor basically comes down
to economy if you are confident that the
other team will be rolling into sight
with aks ops or kriegs then you may as
well save the money for a diffuse kit or
some extra utility now although this is
basically the only sound argument
against head armor
it is very difficult to overstate the
importance of a defuse kit or just
one well-timed flash or smoke and if you
look at the stats of basically every
professional cs go tournament weapons
that can one tap make up the majority of
kills every time that being said there
are absolutely circumstances in which
the cts will definitely want to buy head
armor for starters if you are not 100
certain that the t's aren't on a force
eco or bonus
then you're probably going to want to
make sure you have that saucepan on your
head there is nothing more painful than
dumping thousands of dollars into a full
buy and getting absolutely fried by a w
warrior wielding a mac 10 which
literally happened to jax at the pgl
major instead of forking up cash for
head armor he was a good teammate and
bought a defuse kit
and unfortunately
paid the price are they going to try and
speed it up handles is an arch isn't so
cheap jax is going to go down that's a
big stop puncher inside of the bomb side
he's squashed he can't see anything and
he gets
[Music]
on top of that there are a ton of more
situational reasons that you might want
to pick up head armor the most common of
which is probably
if you win pistol on ct and you're
buying up in the second round absolutely
buy head armor the enemy team is either
gonna save and have glocks which you
definitely don't wanna get one tapped by
or they're gonna force up most likely
into
mac 10s or gales which you also don't
want to get one tapped by it also just
generally eliminates aim punch protects
against a pistoling opera and can even
save you from a frustrating wall bang
knowing when to not buy head armor is a
tricky thing you not only have to have a
good understanding of the economy and
what position you're playing but who
you're playing against it can sometimes
take a couple of rounds of sort of
feeling your opponent out before you
know what you can get away with now for
many of you this is common knowledge
pros and plebs alike have been ditching
the bucket for some extra cash on ct's
side for years now but with valerian
serving as a gateway of sorts
a ton of new players are getting into cs
many of whom have genuine questions
about the intricacies of armor and the
economy at large speaking of valadante
which also has a two-tiered armor system
the conversation surrounding when and
when not to upgrade one's armor has
become even more prominent so
what about valorant what about yamcha
what about yamcha well since this is
valorent we're talking about their armor
system is ostensibly a
carbon copy of cs goes
that said
they're actually a lot less alike than
you might think valorance shields come
in two forms light and heavy both
shields absorb 66.6
of incoming damage but they both have
thresholds
light shields which cost 400 credits
will break after only 25 hit points
heavy shields cost 1 000 credits and
will break after 50 hit points that's a
huge difference in price but as in cs go
there are a ton of situations where that
extra money and extra armor will make
all the difference since there are
weapons that will one shot headshot you
depending on your armor situation that's
especially true since crucially a heavy
shield isn't just a helmet it protects
your body as well on top of that damage
fall off invalorant is way more
prominent for example the sheriff does
159 damage to the head from 0 to 30
meters that's enough to one tap even
through heavy shields
but once you go past that 30 meter mark
the headshot damage falls to 145
leaving your opponent with 5 hp now that
may not seem like a lot the reason it's
so good is because it's so bad to be
dead
it's not like life so great
so you might be wondering if there are
so many benefits why wouldn't you just
upgrade your armor whenever you have the
credits well just like cs valorant has a
ton of weapons that will inflict a
one-shot headshot regardless of armor
and one of those weapons the vandal
makes up for almost 45 percent of all
kills across events forsaken performing
under the pressure to get to ames the
reset
ridiculous
it's also worth mentioning that the
phantom valorance amalgamation of the a4
and a1s essentially can still one shot
kill up to 15 meters so although it's
not a great distance you technically
still aren't safe from the other premium
rifle either and then of course there's
the little things like chamber that
french bastard who gets to pull guns out
of his ass that all one shot kill if
you're facing up against chamber which
nowadays let's be honest you always are
heavy armor might be a futile purchase
on top of that you never really know
what weapons your opponent is going to
buy reading the enemy's economy is a lot
easier invalid than this in cs go since
you can literally see the enemy team's
money but with abilities one tricks and
off-color guns being as strong as they
are
you never really know it's all very
situational in my head i do like
three to four like if else statements in
my head before i decide whether or not i
want to buy the extra 13 armor for one
grand it's how much money do we have how
much money do i have how much money does
the other team have what map are we
playing
right and how many rounds are left in
the half and i guess sometimes players
don't really can't really wrap their
head around a lot of that kind of stuff
and they can't make a logical decision
and they're just like okay well i don't
really know so you know i'm just gonna
buy it because better safe than sorry
now realistically we could just end the
video right here but it wouldn't be a
cracked if we didn't include a good old
case study people have been talking
about armor and valoran since launch
but recently it's become even more of a
hot button issue a lot of that is owed
to nrg esports over the past couple of
months they have been shaking things up
due to their performances on half buys
and eco rounds valorant commentator bren
took notice and checked out the numbers
he found out that during a half buy or
eco nrg had a win rate of
66.6 percent
optic and xset were higher but didn't
have the same amount of rounds played
making nrg a clear outlier now their
success with less money can be
attributed to a lot of things but what's
interesting is that energy also seems to
skip out on heavy shields quite
frequently even when they have the money
and in the clips we see here they still
won rounds with light armor now it
doesn't always work out in their favor
but skipping out on armor still has its
benefits and nrg's commitment to
experimenting with their economy can be
extremely useful in the long run it
definitely made a lot of sense because
they they had overall more buy rounds
when they shouldn't have but they were
getting stomped like 8-0 or something
and like they had a lot more buy rounds
than they should have they were able to
afford a lot more util than they should
have so in the end of the day like they
had a better fighting chance
um albeit it didn't really pan out but
they had a lot more chances to succeed
by doing that it's for sure a risky
strat but it's not insane the vandal and
chamber are very much a part of the
current meta so if the enemy team is
running that setup heavy shields could
be rendered useless as a player you need
to make sure that you consider all of
the possibilities if you know the team
you're playing or if you know
you know like the map you're playing on
it's like breeze for example right i
think running light armor and keeping
your bank healthy is totally a viable
option because
nine out of 10 people on that server are
gonna be running vandal now this may all
seem a little bit extra and in the grand
scheme of things even unimportant but
let me tell you armor is a very
expensive part of cs go and valerian's
respective economies and like i
mentioned before both these games are
about making very subtle economic
decisions that will in turn affect your
mechanical decisions that can then
affect the outcome of an entire match
but even players at the highest level
don't always have a perfect
understanding of how armor works
that or it's just the creeping suspicion
that it's always better to be safe than
sorry did you know
that you don't need to rebuy your armor
if you have more than 50 points as t and
57 points as ct i actually never knew
that
and someone crunched the numbers rpk
wasted seven thousand dollars asl one
cologne rebuying armor he didn't need to
use that to pay his taxes he certainly
could have but what if you only take one
sliver of damage over the course of the
round is it still worth rebuying your
armor or should you just leave it as is
for that
i'm going to direct you to colton and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about
if you're a league player or a battle
royale guy and you made it this far into
the video
let me know in the comments because you
are the real heroes now i promise at
some point we'll actually get to talk
about tech again but for now let me
break down what i think is probably the
biggest difference between
counter-strike and valorance armor
implementations like dimitri already
mentioned valoran's armor absorbs
two-thirds 66 of incoming damage up to
25 or 50 hp
cs armor on the other hand absorbs 200
hp worth of damage to specific parts of
the body based on the armor penetration
rate of the gun you're being shot by so
let's look at an example from
counter-strike and for simplicity's sake
we're just going to look at the rifles
excluding the og and the sg on average
they will do 73 of their damage to your
health and 27 percent to your armor
these are basically complete opposites
it's incredibly difficult to take
serious damage to your armor and live
and counter-strike but downright
commonplace to have your armor broken in
a valerian gunfight shelling out the
money to repair your armor in cs is
rarely worthwhile and thanks to machine
now you know the thresholds for when you
should because i definitely didn't know
you valorante players get ready to keep
repairing your armor like you're playing
apex the obvious impact of all this is
that the economic advantage when winning
consecutive rounds tends to be less
pronounced and valorent than it is in cs
go because you're spending a lot of
extra money repairing your armor but
that's all i've got for you guys
you know
we really should consider not using that
title card when i'm talking about tax
shooters it's just blatantly untrue and
i don't think anything and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about so when it comes to you guys our
lovely viewers should you buy head armor
or heavy armor when you have the credits
more often than not
i'm going to say
yes but there is an asterisk there are
so many different things going on in any
given round and in the majority of elos
it's important to focus on your gameplay
aiming and the fundamentals having that
extra head armor will protect you in a
lot of situations plus it'll give you
peace of mind in a scary slow methodical
tack shooter that is sort of inherently
designed to mess with your psyche
is it better to buy a famas with util or
an m4 without
there's no one clear answer it depends
but if you're getting rolled by a t-side
running five aks and you're running
short on utility or you keep getting
deleted by a chamber every time you peek
mid maybe it's time to start thinking
critically about your armor buys just
don't come crying to me if you get one
tapped by a bison because you upgraded
to an og instead of buying head armor
whatever you buy
just
live with it
valerian's like not even in my top five
favorite attack shooters f wearing top
two five textures i would i would
literally take arma over [__]
valerian bro i would take kronker over
valor in a [__] heartbeat i don't
know if there is like a search and
destroy mode and crunker but if there
isn't there should be and i would take
franco around two seconds that's that's
the endpoint right there
not even not even top five i'm trying to
sound like a child right
he's she's full of life she doesn't know
about climate change yet okay let's do
this
what does she what do people in anime do
they get like
i don't know bro
oh my god let me listen to the eye